>> Tucker: IN THE LAST FEW DAYS
SENATOR KENOSHACOREY AND BOOKER
HARRIS ENDORSED BIDEN.
THEY HAD NOTHING BUT EEIF YOU
HAVIVE PRAISE.
>> I ENDORSING JOE BIDEN FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
WE NEED A LEADER WHO REALLY DOES
CARE ABOUT THE PEOPLE AND CAN
THEREFORE UNIFY THE PEOPLE.
I BELIEVE JOE CAN DO THAT.
>> OUR DIVISIONS IN THE COUNTRY
IS OUR WEAKNESS.
WE NEED THE CANDIDATE THAT CAN
BEST UNIFY ALL OF US AND THAT IS
JOE BIDEN.
>> Tucker: NOW PEOPLE WHO JUST
GOT HERE FROM BATS BATSWANA WHO
SPEAK ENGLISH THOSE US WITH A
VCR OR DVR DIDN’T QUITE MAKE
SENSE.
LESS THAN A YEAR AGO CORY BOOKER
WAS WINDING THAT JOE BIDEN WOULD
BE DISASTROUS FOR THE PARTY.
>> CONCERN ABOUT JOE BIDEN
CARRYING THE BAY BALL ACROSS THE
END LINE WITHOUT FUMBLING.
CASTRO HAS SOME LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS THERE WAS A LOT OF
MOMENTS WHERE A NUMBER OF US
WERE LOOKING ON THE STAGE WHEN
HE TENDS TO GO ON SOMETIMES.
AT ONE POINT TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE IN COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE
LISTENING TO RECORD PLAYERS.
DEFINITELY MOMENTS WHEN YOU
LISTEN TO JOE BIDEN AND YOU JUST
WONDER.
>> Tucker: WHAT DID CORY BOOKER
JUST SAY?
HE SAID JOE BIDEN IS SENILE.
TOTALLY OUT OF IT.
HE CAN’T CARRY THE BALL BECAUSE
IS HE TOO OLD.
>> IS HE NOT CAPABLE OF JUST
BEING PRESIDENT.
THAT’S WHAT HE SAID IN THAT
TAPE.
KAMALA HARRIS MEANWHILE SAID
THAT BIDEN WAS A RACIST.
>> I’M GOING TO NOW DIRECT THIS
ADVICE TO VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN.
I DO NOT BELIEVE YOU ARE A
RACIST BUT YOU ALSO WORKED WITH
THEM TO OPPOSE BUSING.
AND THERE WAS A LITTLE GIRL IN
CALIFORNIA WHO WAS PART OF THE
SECOND CLASS TO INTEGRATE HER
PUBLIC SCHOOL.
AND SHE WAS BUSED TO SCHOOL
EVERY DAY.
AND THAT LITTLE GIRL WAS ME.
[LAUGHTER]
SO SHE IS FOR BUSING NOW.
ACTUALLY SHE IS NOT FOR BUSING.
NO ONE WAS EVER FOR BUSING.
EVERYONE HAIGHT THE BUSING
PARTICULARLY BLACK PARENTS.
WHATEVER.
SHE WAS STILL CALLING BIDEN A
RACIST.
I’M NOT CALLING YOU A RACIST,
SO WHAT HAPPENED?
HE WAS SENILE, HE WAS A BIGOT.
AND NOW HE MUST BE PRESIDENT.
WELL, THE ANSWER, OF COURSE, IS
IT WAS ALL A SHAM.
HARRIS NEVER REALLY MEANT IT
LIKE MOST CLAIMS OF RACISM, YOU
HEAR IN POLITICS, IT WAS TOTALLY
FAKE AND TOTALLY TRANSACTIONAL.
MARK STEYN IS AN AUTHOR AND
COLUMNIST.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
SO, WHY NOT JUST SAY IN THEIR
ENDORSEMENTS LOOK THE GUY IS
SENILE AND IS HE A BIGOT BUT I’M
FOR HIM ANYWAY?
>> YEAH.
THAT’S BASICALLY WHAT THEY ARE
SIGNING ON TO.
THE LITTLE GIRL ON THE BUS AS
SENATOR HARRIS DESCRIBED HERSELF
IS NOW ON JOE BIDEN’S BUS AND
WHETHER THAT’S A SCHOOL DISTRICT
ANYONE WANTS TO BE DRIVEN TO
REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
IT’S ONE WHEREAS CORY BOOKER
POINTED OUT CRAZY UNCLE JOE WHEN
HE IS NOT SNIFFING YOUR HAIR
SNEAKING INTO YOUR BEDROOM AND
PUTTING RECORD PLAYERS ON ALL
NIGHT IN WHICH TO INDOCTRINATE
YOU.
THE FACT IS HE HAS ACTUALLY
GOTTEN WORSE SINCE CORY BOOKER
SAID THAT WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS
SOMETHING QUITE EXTRAORDINARY.
HIS RIVAL PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES ARE BASICALLY NOW
SIGNING ON TO A DEAD HUSK OF A
CANDIDATE IN THE INTEREST OF
SO-CALLED UNITY.
I TAKE IT THEY HAVE ALL BEEN
PROMISED THE VICE PRESIDENTIAL
SLOT.
AMY KLOBUCHAR GAVE IT AWAY TODAY
BUT I THINK KAMALA AND CORY HAVE
BEEN PROMISED IT TOO.
GOD KNOWS IF ANYBODY COULD USE
SEVEN OR EIGHT VICE PRESIDENTIAL
RUNNING MATES IT’S JOE BIDEN.
WE ARE SEEING SOMETHING
EXTRAORDINARY HERE.
TRUMP WAS THE ANTICONVENTIONAL
CANDIDATE.
HE HAD NO MINDERS.
HE WAS ALL CANDIDATE AND NO
MINDERS.
THIS CAMPAIGN NOW IS ALL MINDERS
AND NO CANDIDATE.
HE HAS GOT ALL THESE SO-CALLED
SURROGATES NOW WHO HAVE ENDORSED
HIM.
BUT THEY ARE ENDORSING SOMETHING
THAT ISN’T THERE.
AND THE QUESTION THEN BECOMES
WHO IS THE THERE THAT THEY ARE
PLANNING ON ACTUALLY RUNNING
THIS SHOW?
IT’S THE WEIRDEST PRESIDENTIAL
SELECTION THAT HAS BEEN SEEN IN
MODERN TIMES.
>> Tucker: WELL, THEY ARE ALL
HOME HEALTH AIDS AND ALL NURSES
IN EFFECT.
I MEAN, IS THERE ANYTHING THAT
KAMALA HARRIS WON’T SAY?
I MEAN WHEN THEY SAID TO HER,
LOOK, KAMALA HARRIS HAVE YOU GOT
TO ENDORSE THE GUY DO YOU THINK
SHE SAID OH BUT I CALLED HIM A
RACIST I CAN’T BECAUSE RACISM
DOESN’T MATTER OR DID SHE FORGET
THAT SHE EVEN SAID THAT?
>> NO.
RACISM IS JUST A BIT OF CHITCHAT
ON ONE SIDE OF THE POLITICAL
DIVIDE.
SO, THAT AS YOU KNOW, IF YOU ARE
THE GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA AND YOU
ARE AROUND IN BLACK FACE WHAT
THE HELL THAT WAS A YOUTHSFUL
INDISCRETION.
IT’S A YOUTHFUL INDISCRETION
WHEN JUSTIN TRUDEAU IS DOING IT
IN EARLY MIDDLE AGE.
THEN, ON THE OTHER SIDE, THESE
THINGS DESTROY YOUR CAREER.
SO WE LIVE IN AN AGE WHERE EVERY
MORNING YOU WAKE UP AND PEOPLE
WITH 50-YEAR CAREERS ARE BEING
VAPOR RISED AND THEN THEN ON THE
OTHER SIDE ON THE DEMOCRAT SIDE
IF IT’S ONE OF YOUR OWN, HEY YOU
RACIST, YOU SUPPORT YOU HAD
BUSING.
THAT’S JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
LIGHT SOCIAL CHITCHAT BEFORE YOU
START PROGRAM MISSING EVERYBODY
MEDICARE FOR ALL OR OPEN
BORDERS.
>> Tucker: CHARLIE ROSE MUST BE
WONDERING HOW HE CAN GET BACK IN
THE GAME TONIGHT I WOULD THINK.